[Music]
French president macarons announcement
of wanting to build a European army to
rival NATO and fend off potential
American influence is a bad idea
with even worse timing and would
undermine seventy years of European
peace as a remainer
I welcome defense secretary Gavin
Williamson calling it an absolutely
crazy idea just like German Chancellor
Merkel's fateful open-door policy
unilaterally letting 1 million Syrian
refugees months before our bricks evoke
macrons unilateral announcement came
just days before Teresa Mays brexit plan
Merkel and macron have both shown just
how tone-deaf they are to undermining
the --use integrity rather than
fantasizing about an EU army France and
especially Germany would do well to meet
their existing NATO commitment to
spending 2 percent of their GDP on
defense France currently spends about
1.8 percent in Germany only spends 1.2%
countries that narrowly missed a
populist right-wing front national
government and they nativist right-wing
AFD coalition should repair their glass
houses before throwing too many stones
at Trump's America in such a populist
climate the idea of a centralized
European army is a scary one ya know I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a shoe with you on
several points one I can take it over
one they never said they were going to
fuse armed forces to create a European
army what they're going to do is have a
European no they didn't they're not
going to do that there is it's not wait
wait a minute it's not going to weaken
NATO
it's going to supplement NATO in areas
of operation where NATO has no interest
such as for example Libya where it might
have been quite useful to have something
at our disposal so what's the train hold
on the chain of command is we follow
NATO chain rawand we just don't have we
get how under the NATO nuclear umbrella
but wait it's not actually happening for
decades so don't worry oh well you'll
hear from the EU commitment deputy on
your German point it's actually a very
good idea because at the moment is you
Germany only spends 1.2 percent of its
GDP that is because they'd cannot for
political reasons have the largest arms
forces in Europe if they also were
allowed to commit to an eighth to an
East European force it would enable
Germany to be a bigger military presence
without skill frightening the horses so
let's just have a usual Deputy
Commissioner Frederick no more greener
we're not building a European army here
nobody is doing a European army we are
investing to make sure that European
Union member states have the
capabilities to provide more to their
own defence and to be more credible more
reliable more active security providers
in our region and in the world yeah
Rachel can I just say I think the first
the first thing the first point I made
is that it the propaganda value and the
timing of these statements I've got to
concede absolutely on the optics it
really forces every brick city is the
dream of a federalist Europe and look at
both examples I gave of Merkel and Mac
on both before crucial moments in our
domestic political debate so you and I
are on the same side of well you're
attacking is the political timing of it
what about the actual good you're gonna
do this in for a start do you know I
mean what crypto we're gonna use what
equipment we're gonna use who's gonna
train them where they're going to be
trained what's the central what's the
central command element gonna consist of
how are they going to deploy them where
they decide who goes where the
infighting with this would be just
incurred it would be able on its own the
whole thing is just incredibly stupid
and let's just set of what we've got and
it works to a certain extent which is
NATO okay and the UN and other areas of
the world let's just cope with that for
a moment because Europe bounded together
quite happily to defeat to defeat the
end
[Laughter]
and by the way don't question that they
wanted to be an army this is Angela
Merkel jean-claude juncker already said
that a common European army would show
the world there'd never said it's an
army but the timing is right just as
Majid said Merkel and there are many
arguments that's why she should have let
those folk in but it was absolutely
manna from heaven for the braces this is
I tell you hold on and I hosted a debate
once between Nigel Farage and Nick Clegg
and Faraj said they want to have a
European army and Nick Craig said
absolutist they never want a European
army and so here where this was and I
know you're gonna get angry but this was
supposedly we were going into a common
market where we could have nice cheap
apples and beer and whatever else it was
a nice Italian cheese and now we've got
a flag to Parliament's embassies around
the world it is absolutely crazy idea
NATO's delivered European security for
the last 70 years and we should feel
very proud of it should we undermine
that by forming a separate military
force absolutely not
to begin discussing the new EU army is
dangerous and undermines the security
that NATO under eyes because NATO has
actually responded to this I said it yes
this force will be complementary no it's
not a bad idea here we go
this is Deputy Secretary General of NATO
Rose Goethe Miller the notion that the
Europeans as
group should be putting more resources
into defense capabilities into their
Armed Forces it's one that I think is a
very positive thing we're not talking
about some kind of concept of strategic
autonomy but we're talking about
European forces that would be inherently
at one so what she's saying is NATO is
weak we're underfunded as per Trump
points out Russia is dangerous and Trump
is unreliable yes please let's have a
separate complementary force when it
comes to defense and stuff like that
we've always where America's concerned
that change is once you've got new
leadership so I think that's not a bad
boy anybody 24 know 2020 hopefully but I
think the other thing what we have to
look at is number one
Matt crying I don't know what he's
thinking his approval rating at the
moment is 25 percent
I mean his approval ratings worse than
Donald Trump and the same with Merkel
she's standing down as me well so at the
end of the day chances are neither of
them are gonna be there for very long
why would they think that this would be
a good idea and also when you have two
countries that have far-right parties
breathing down their neck this is just
handing the far-right victory some
sanity and I think I interpret that NATO
statement as a an attempt to curtail the
idea by saying it will remain under NATO
control but that's not what macron
macrons only command and control over
because he called it he said we want a
true EU army we don't use those words if
it's under NATO and American command
let's have listened to some of these
words this is French President Lee
Manning micron speaking who is the main
victim Europe and its security I want to
build a real security dialogue with
Russia which is a country I respect a
European country but we must have a
Europe that can defend itself on its own
without relying only on the u.s. we have
to protect ourselves with respect to
China Russia and even the United States
of America that implies that it's not
going to be under NATO control you know
because he's distinguishing it even for
us as well I think it's dangerous
I think it's ambiguous actually well
also why don't these countries choosers
I think Majid you said riders are why
don't they pay the way that's needed
Internet
so it's all very well they don't even
pay them subs effectively to have NATO
it's like an insurance policy I'm sure
you have them on your house but you
don't actually pay the full rate then
where else would you get away with
robbing all no Trump his rather caustic
and rather bombastic in the way he makes
the board he is on to something if
you're meant to and of course as always
the Brits I think is it the Brits in the
Italian five other countries we pay 2%
yeah I'm so we do as we talk with by and
large Brits do know you're gonna do as
you're told because we've got to go to
break
I always do coming up why Nick shouldn't
be punished just for being who he is